[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster i'm constantine kitten and this
is a show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people our brilliant guest
today is a writer
cultural commentator she's the host of
the subversive podcast alex kosciutta
welcome to trigonometry
thank you for having me on it's a
pleasure to be here it's a great
pleasure to have you on the show we've
been meaning to get you on for a long
time
tell us who you are first of all because
you've got an interesting story
which i think informs a lot of the views
that you have as well which we're going
to get to
so tell everybody who are you how are
you where you are what has been the
journey that leads you through life
to be here talking to us oh yeah a a
very long story
which involves a escape from from the
clutches of eastern europe
living in the west for about probably 12
years
in total uh and now back in the last
year
living in the corona bunker in my
hometown in transylvania
so it's been a journey i have to say
but that's uh that's not the only thing
i mean i've been a journalist i've
i've worked in tech now i work in in
finance related to tech
um yeah it's quite quite many things
have happened in the last 12 years and
now like you said they've they've
informed my my view on a lot of things
well an interesting piece of your
journey is uh you were part of i imagine
the sort of brain drain from eastern
europe
people who are young bright uh
well-educated etc going over to the west
uh and you get here you lived in london
for five years
you get a job you you have a good job
you live in london and increasingly you
find that
the sort of promise of everything that
the west
offers particularly the way that it's
sort of configured at the moment
is not fulfilling your actual needs and
wishes and it's increasingly making you
feel
lonely and unhappy um
yes i think that's that's kind of the
pattern that i saw
in myself first and foremost but also in
a lot of people around me
there was this uh prescribed uh
ladder that one must climb up you know
first you get to the west
few you made it maybe you go to school
there that's also
the next step and then you climb your
way through
you know whichever corporate ladder you
you find this is closest to you or
most accessible um the the issue that i
found was that it's it's quite an
absorbing life um especially if you
might have other plans uh you know like
uh as a
as a woman with a female life trajectory
i i wanted
family and and children to be part of
that and
it became a bit complex to do that in in
london
and it seemed to me that you know the
the latter that was
in front of me in terms of career was a
little bit at odds with
the latter that i i wanted because you
know you can you can climb up and you
get more responsibility and you you know
that that becomes the
the major focus point of your life and
you know that that's what you're paid
for
that's what it should be that's what
you're responsible for um
but in in parallel to that you know i
i wanted to just have a more flexible
existence
and that's why i moved back home and now
i work remotely which
is you know quite a blessing and uh yeah
i'm grateful to be able to do that
and alex do you think a lot of these a
lot of women feel the same way as you do
in the west but they can't express it
this feeling that you have um
i i think i think a lot of them are
are they struggle with dating they
struggle with
uh you know figuring out things in time
um because you know men and women
typically have different
uh kind of biological timelines that
they have to deal with
which is something that it's not that
isn't really spoken about
very clearly in the mainstream um i can
understand why people are trying to
encourage women to you know be
independent
and and climb climb these ladders that
are supposedly so
extremely amazing that everyone needs to
be on them
um and i i think that the issue is that
a lot of them wake up a little bit maybe
late
and it's it's it's a bit complicated to
to to make your bed when you're let's
say 37 and then you think oh should i
freeze my eggs and i'm like oh
maybe it's a bit late for that to be
honest it's it's you know it's it's a
complicated
thing and my my issue was that you know
people didn't really prepare
me or my friends or anyone for for the
for these decisions or these uh these
forks in the road that you have to
eventually confront if you're if you're
a woman and if you if
your plan isn't just to you know
dedicate your whole existence to
mckinsey or
whoever you know wants to pay you lots
of money
and alex why do you think it is that we
don't talk about this why is this
a taboo subject because the reality is
it's a biological fact
if you want kids you the best time to do
it is
the earlier the better really what part
you know past the age of
20 whenever it is why are we not talking
about it
i think there's kind of an egalitarian
assumption at the core of
of um of our societies especially in the
west that you know
uh if you want it you can have it you
can have it all you know you you want to
increase your optionality
you want to be you know you want to be
equal in
in status to men obviously um
and the the main source of status that
exists now in
in the west is are these hierarchies are
you know the corporate hierarchy or
academia or wherever it's a place that
will take
more than nine to five to to invest in
if you want the status
um you know in in more traditional
societies you know older women had
status through other means they were
you know the the proverbial wise crone
that gave advice or some form of
matriarch or something we don't have
those
those levels anymore you have
fortune 500 or you know pick pick your
pick your industry uh or you have
nothing
or you know your your consumption
options diminish if you don't
make enough money to consume or continue
i don't know going on trips or
gaining getting other status objects
that are important
um and i think that's a major tension
and so you say that that's a major
tension but ultimately
by women not fulfilling this sort of i
mean let's be fair like a
biological urge surely they're denying
number one a part of themselves but
number two
making themselves miserable in the long
term
yeah i think for for humans it's hard to
tell what's going to make you happy in
the long term
and what's what's going to make you
miserable um
and when you're for example if you're if
you're a young professional
in the in the big city the whole city is
constructed around
single life it's constructed around
optimizing your
options uh you know for consuming cool
stuff
going to cool places mingling with cool
people which are
coincidentally all single that's the
lifestyle
it's it's built around and if you want
to opt out because essentially that's
what you're doing
by having a child you kind of have to
accept that you're nuking this lifestyle
and you're moving on to a lifestyle that
is you know
has involves other people has some
constraints
you know you reduce your optionality by
by having children and i can understand
why some people
either postpone this decision for a long
time until they get into hot water
for biological reasons or they um they
just
don't want to do it at all and then
maybe they make up reasons like i don't
know the
polar ice caps are melting or something
so yeah there
are different reasons but you know the
reasons to have children are
are not as many as as they used to be
and one of the things i think is a core
of the work that you do your writing
your commentary etc is exploring
the the sort of constraints that human
beings place on themselves
and almost need sometimes in order to
live a happy and fulfilled life and i
find that very interesting watching some
of the other interviews that you've done
there is there's a sort of inbuilt
assumption that no one in in in a
liberal quote-unquote society questions
which is
the more free you are to be an atomized
individual
uh who's free to do whatever they want
the better and it is automatically
assumed that anything that
constrains you anything that shapes your
behavior anything that encourages or
pushes you in any direction that
is counter to that is automatically
wrong bad evil
you know part of the patriarchy in this
case or whatever else it might be
uh so give us your thoughts on that that
sort of
uh struggle between freedom uh and
the constraints that sometimes human
beings actually benefit from
yeah i think the this conception of
freedom you know this kind of rational
liberated individual that we've
instantiated in our flavor of liberalism
is quite
new historically because if you look
back at for example you know how
aristotle uh
conceptualized freedom it was
essentially in a way of freedom
from the the base desires it was kind of
self-control being kind of cultivating
oneself to the point where
you become a master of yourself that
conception of freedom
we haven't cultivated at all freedom at
the moment is freedom from
you know constrained freedom from
tradition freedom from
any sort of conventional knowledge that
you know might have helped
our ancestors coordinate or you know
build a robust society or you know just
to just at least understand what's going
on in each other's heads
um and now i think we're at the point
where a lot of the freedom that
people ask for is freedom from the body
i think you see this a lot with you know
kind of these transhumanists you know
transgenderism
it's the idea that you know not only am
i not constrained by tradition i'm not
even constrained by
you know the chains of of physical
existence
i'm you know this is but a skin that i
can change like in a video game because
you know it's there's not really any
reason for it not to
be interchangeable like you know why
would you constrain my freedom live and
let live you know
don't tread on me that's it i think
that's
quite a limited thing because there is
there is wisdom in a lot of these
traditions
there is a lot of coordination value um
there is there is value in me
understanding what you think and what
your moral standards are and what you
might
might what i might be able to expect
from you um
when we're in society together um that's
something that you know
we don't really put that much value on
anymore
but i think you know it's something that
goes out the window um
and i think with with this concept of
freedom where it's just like you know
leave me alone um it's also an
impoverishment like for example if you
are
an 18 year old girl and you don't get
you know traditional instruction
in life you go on the internet
find the easiest source of money which
is probably either you know going on
seeking arrangement or only fans or
something like that
you fulfill your expedient needs to get
some money to
i don't know by purses or whatever is
interesting to you at 18.
um and these things might have long-term
consequences the idea that
because you're 18 you're now a sovereign
individual ready to make choices you're
you know the rational human going out
and you know kicking ass and taking
names
i don't know if that's the case so um
something which i think is very
important there and i'm increasingly
aware that this conversation might sound
like three people from the 1950s having
a conversation about morality
good but but i do actually think this is
important because one of the things you
touch on there when you talk about
freedom and particularly this only fans
whatever arrangement is the freedom to
do whatever you want
in the sexual realm has sort of
clashed i would say with the fact that
sex
has consequences beyond just you know
the immediate experience we've sort of
lost touch with that is that fair to say
yeah yeah i think people try to mitigate
the fact that sex has consequences
through the norm of consent which is now
the
the big cuddle that comes in and you we
try to solve everything with consent and
if you had bad sex oh it must have been
the consent was wrong you didn't really
give consent
um the idea the problem with sex is that
it is very complicated and it's it's
something that happens
beneath the rational level there's a lot
of negotiation that's you know
ties into i don't know body language
pheromones
um implicit cultural assumptions about
what's to be expected or not
um things that really don't work at the
level of a contract
and we've tried to just you know force
everything into this contractual mold
and
it's not surprising to me that the young
people are confused about sexual norms
and that
for example maybe young women really are
having a bad time
um you know because there's a lot of
chat about me too and how all of these
cases are ridiculous like you know the
aziz ansari case where there was this
ambiguous event that you know
it definitely wasn't rape but it was
kind of shoehorned into the
non-consensual rape mold after after the
fact
but it was clearly um a lot of
miscommunication in an
area that is is fraught with you know
it's it's a dangerous thing to have sex
especially as a woman
you know historically you were burdened
with with children
you know there was also kind of the the
shame over hang which people
uh which people used to use to kind of
control these these situations
so i understand why um
why it's it's confusing and we're
lacking a language to to deal with these
things because
you know it's like trying to write
poetry in binary code
you know it's it's pretty hard to to
understand
uh if this is your only tool that you
have in your toolbox yeah consent
okay um yeah i think we need to get a
bit more nuanced about
about sex and you say we need to get a
bit more nuance about
sex isn't part of the problem that we
now treat sex as we would treat
a sort of an experience we we use it as
a way to
say oh i've done this i've done this
position i've had this
and actually what you're getting away
from what the act was originally
intended for
and also really denying the bonding
element of it
yeah exactly i think um because we're so
used to to having
you know consumption be our main way of
interacting with the world
uh we've we've reduced this this act
into into the platform of consumption i
think probably porn culture has
something to do with it because
sex is a consumer product after all it's
everywhere i mean
you know the first time i got on the
internet i was probably
13 years old that was a relatively long
time ago i found porn
in 20 minutes so i'm sure it's quite
accessible to everyone and everyone's a
bit
you know a little bit oversaturated with
it and yeah it is it is a product at
this point
um so i i think you know
with with dating apps we've moved into
another realm where people are
very much kind of tokenized and then
commoditized
transforming these experiences into into
simply
you know notches or checklist boxes is
not surprising if
that's kind of the the angle that we've
taken and that we
we always have this kind of market
filter between us and the other person
um with social media as well like you
always kind of have this
this layer of technology intermediating
the the connection between you and
someone else
and the the algorithm knows you know
which one is your best picture
it knows you know how to how to present
you in in the best way so that you get
you increase your consumption options
with the other people on the on the
platform
um it's i think this really does skew
people and how they think about their
own sexuality
um and how they think about how they
should be relating to other people
it these things have become the norm
quite quite fast like it's
it's been surprising to me to see how
fast dating apps have become
normative um and you know a lot of
people i i've met my husband on a dating
app
and i think it's you know it's a it can
be a great technology if you
use it judiciously and treat it treat it
the way it is but i can
can also see that you know it warps the
the dating landscape quite heavily uh in
many ways because this is not
natural this is not how people interact
you know um
it it really is it's terrible for funny
people
it's it's it's not the best you know
place
to meet funny people that's okay neither
of us is funny
just prove that there i did a little
joke she didn't laugh
i'm not crazy about the the
self-deprecating humor you guys are
obviously funny and
uh yeah sorry
good excellent that's the kind of
response we want but alex
listen we're obviously just joking
around but i find so much of what you're
saying really interesting and refreshing
and let me ask you this because i guess
historically
this whole thing i'm sure part of it is
driven by technology but part of it is
also driven by
a rebellion against over-prescribed
hyper-constraining social norms
you know girls don't do this boys you
know don't behave like that this is how
we're all
all supposed to be is it sort of like
the jumper was a bit
too warm so we've started picking away
the threads and now the whole thing is
just falling apart
yeah i think there's that's that's a
component as well
because you know humanity and
how people evolved was always under some
form of constraint
um you know like people keep keep
complaining about the fact that you know
women have hypergamous instincts
and you know what does that mean for
people who are not familiar
yeah it's the idea that you know women
in the worst of cases it's framed as
women being gold diggers but it's the
idea that women tend to be attracted to
men who are
competent have resources you know okay
money
um and you know have kind of status
signals have show power
they're they they're high status men and
they kind of tend to date up
as much as they can across these
hierarchies to you know to
to to get someone who can secure those
resources for herself but mostly
the the framing is that is for her
offspring and that you know
increases chances for survival that's
that's kind of the evo psycho
explanation for it
um so the the idea that you know you
have hypergamy but hypergamy
um evolved in under conditions where
women um were quite restricted in what
they could
do sexually i mean there's very very few
societies
ever in in the history of man where
there weren't there wasn't some form of
kind of like patriarchy or matriarchy
that controlled
you know the sexuality of young girls in
some ways and essentially these things
co-evolved you have you have these
controls that are social controls on
sexuality like okay you know who are you
gonna marry
you know we need to make sure that
you're a virgin before you know these
are quite restrictive
ways to to deal with sexuality and then
you have these kind of hypergamous
instincts or you know
instincts for for women to you know to
seek out dating you know these these top
status guys
um and the problem is once you lift all
sexual controls you know you lift the
lid of patriarchy
you essentially have this very strong
urge that women have to date only the
apex guys which now
manifests in and essentially what we see
on dating apps where you know a very
small
fraction of men gets get to go on all
the dates so women are very very picky
but back in the day when you know you
have patriarchy or you know insert your
control mechanism of choice um
controlling who
girls got to marry you know forming
alliances using kind of
gearing of female sexuality in different
directions
um you know did this instinct existed
but it didn't get to
to go go buck wild so it's uh
it's it's interesting to to think about
we know why it's happening obviously
it's it's an increase in freedom
but it's also very destabilizing in
terms of you know
marriage rates in terms of people you
know actually getting to have offspring
who gets married there's you know it's
definitely a very novel
in the history of humanity overall
obviously i'm sure there are some tribes
in the amazon people can you know
come in and say oh no no they had a
strange you know super sexual matriarchy
but it's a fraction of of one percent of
civilizations most had some form of
control
hey constantine do you love trigonometry
of course
incredible interviews hilarious live
streams
hard-hitting satire plus my handsome
jawline
whatever takes away from your hairline
but if you do love trigonometry
and you want to support us there's only
one place to do that
and that's on locals yes locals is a
brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show
and other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community
for people who love trigonometry that's
right it's a place for you to hang out
with like-minded people
share thoughts memes and discuss the
show you can enjoy it for free
but it also gives you the option of
supporting us for
as little as seven dollars a month and
if you want to give more
you can we have incredible rewards for
our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one on two chats with me
and kcat
get in join our community by hitting the
link
in the description and the pin comment
below see you there guys
and alex we're talking about this and
saying you know that women have greater
choice than ever before and women
but in many ways this society and this
culture
it's more geared and designed for men
than it is for women
because men have abundance of choice
they don't have to commit
you have access to an act which can
present present you with literally
thousands of thousands of options
why do you have to commit to one woman
yeah it's you know they they call this
the the apex fallacy you know people say
oh men
men they have they have all the choices
it's not all men
it's it's a small it's a small fraction
of men at the top
which you know tend to tend to win out
and you know almost all games
um and yeah i think it's um
you know it's kind of saying that men
have a lot of options
is you know kind of framing it a little
bit uh you know it's just a bit of an
exaggeration
he was just talking about himself now
yeah exactly yeah
thanks well you're funny guys
excellent destroyed with your own facts
and logic
but but sure but if i push back on that
you know there's a lot of women
saying you know and quite understandably
so that you know that it's very
difficult to meet a guy it's very
difficult to settle down with someone
there's a lot of women who hit their
late 30s where all the good men
gone you see it time and time again on
social media does that not prove my
point or have i got it wrong
no i think i think there are many many
losers in this system
um i i'm not sure there's probably more
like really hardcore winners that are
men overall
in in the system i mean it depends what
you think winning is if you want to you
know build a build a sustainable harem
and you know retire
maybe at 50 with uh i don't know a
cohort of women at one point that
probably that is winning for some people
but i think even even for the men who
you know get to go on all these dates
and they
they you know get to you know uh yeah be
be the top guy
they probably at one point you know
would want to you know have a more
stable existence maybe want to have
offspring as well you know have a legacy
have more
baby chads or whatever they imagine
their legacy to be so it is
it is hard even for them because the
problem is if
if you if this system essentially is
feeding off the insecurities of women
because they they don't get to have the
relationships they want
they don't get to go on you know on the
dates with someone who wants to date
them
for you know a long-term relationship
you know the women on the apps at one
point they they
you know have have some issues like it's
you know it really
does mess up your um i know your
self-esteem in a way when you really
you know you you can go on many dates
that's no problem people will date you
but uh if the guy you want to date
doesn't want to be in a relationship
with you it does kind of scar
you mentally and especially if you know
if for example 10 years ago
you were i know in college and you you
know you met some guy at a party and
you know two weeks later he was your
boyfriend this doesn't happen anymore
and now you have you know a very
contractual type of relationship and
then maybe after two months they're like
oh
should we be exclusive and and you know
layers upon layers of commitment that
didn't used to exist in in the past uh
it does kind of
leave you a little bit like okay you
know it's uh it's it's very hard to get
to that level of commitment even to be
someone's girlfriend
um and this this is kind of a change
that that happened
fell to me quite suddenly like maybe six
or five or six years ago
the standard shifted from you meet
someone in real life and you know things
are
a bit not traditional but you get to
have a boyfriend at one point
to you kind of get to interact with the
algorithm and the algorithm
will serve you whoever it wants and then
you kind of have to
go through this very contractual you
know stress
stressful situation um but yeah
i think the the women are losing out
here obviously they're not getting what
they want
the men at the bottom you know forget
about it yeah
they're not you know they should just
delete the apps um
and some men are having a really good
time
that's what i could say for a while so
we sort of diagnosed the problem in that
if i can sum it up succinctly
we've got too much of the wrong kind of
freedom which has resulted in all of
this
so to put it very clearly so what's
what's
i mean there'll be people watching this
going so what are you saying you're
saying women should be back in the
kitchen that's how you
you know get back to the way that things
ought to be
uh it's it's it's a it's a really tough
one because obviously once once you've
you've lifted the lid on on freedom it's
it's quite nice
it's an enticing proposition you know
you don't want to put the lid back on
i do think that women would be best
served and i think men as well to
understand these dynamics
to understand that you know these apps
are not matchmaking apps to understand
the nature of the
the two markets that are clashing there
the market for long-term relationships
and the market for sex
um and that not all dating is dating and
um i also wish that women if they if
they were more
you know relationship oriented to make
that clear um
and to understand that you know most men
probably will not
want to date you or some some you know
some kind of
guys that you might find attractive will
will reject you if you state that you
want a long-term relationship or
even god forbid that you want to get
married or have children or something
you know i
there are very subtle ways to phrase
this you don't need to be very like
crazy explicit but you know if you if
you for example try to
you know paint a picture of the life
that you'd like to
to lead with you know in in the future
and maybe include that
you want you want to have children or
something like that you can do that in a
in a tactful way and then maybe attract
the type of people that are interested
in that and share your values
um but you know just using the apps on
their own terms
is a sole grinder i do not recommend it
so you can you can use the apps but um
you should you know you should kind of
understand what you're getting yourself
into
um and you know the more people
understand about these dynamics in
general the more they can
maybe cultivate more of the you know the
the aristotelian
type of freedom where uh they they kind
of understand that the world has
constraints and that
it's probably wise for them to set
constraints on themselves to be able to
navigate the world
because if you're just going going whole
hog on the you know
live and let live thing bad things might
happen just saying
from experience but also from from what
i've seen around me
and alex how much responsibility do you
think feminism
needs to take for this issue because you
know feminism
you know at the start very very positive
but where we are now you know you can be
anything you can do anything you want
blah blah blah blah
blah and we are where we are now
yeah i think you know feminism this
third fourth wave feminism is
essentially an outgrowth out of that
of that same idea of okay you are the
you know homunculus behind the eyes you
know pulling the strings being super
rational
you know making decisions you're you're
not tied to
your biology you shouldn't be tied by uh
by you know uh tradition or any sort of
constraint
i understand the the impulse you know
it's it's the idea that you
you want to be free uh that's that's
great uh but
as i said you know you've thrown out the
baby with the with the bathwater here
and
it was a pretty precious baby and it was
also a baby that coordinated everyone
and
and you know you can see a lot of
uh consequences of of this move towards
um kind of 100 individualism and the
idea that you know we don't really see
marriage rates are plummeting
fertility rates are plummeting across
the west or across you know kind of
places that adopted this vision of the
individual um so to me
feminism is just one flavor of this the
same
philosophy that says okay you know
the body society whatever is outside of
this
almost metaphysical nucleus that makes
the decisions
um is is uh you know is an imposition
i don't need you can dispense with that
and you you actually studied gender
studies
yeah i i have a degree my undergrad
was in economics but it was in diversity
management gender and diversity
management
so it's kind of gender studies and in a
business suit
you know it had a bit of a you know
economics flair to it
but it was essentially just nonstop
judith butler and
you know a lot of scientific papers and
yeah it was it was quite a hard exam to
pass i was very surprised because i
thought it was
it was going to be something easy
because it sounded a bit fluffy no
they really wanted to keep up the
appearance that this is science
and they essentially made us learn you
know social science papers
by heart and then know you know
everything from the abstract to the coda
to who participated study design and all
sorts of things
of course after the replication crisis
of probably about 97 of those papers
that i learned for college were uh
yeah we're scrapped but um it's
it's uh you know that's that's what
they're trying to do to sell sell the
science in it
were you quite bought into it at the
time you weren't there to sort of study
with the critical
eye you thought this was going to be
valuable to you
yeah i thought it was um it was an
interesting field i was kind of
interested in feminism
since i was a teenager because you know
growing up in romania being kind of this
a bit of a an outsider girl
you know interested in a lot of you know
kooky things i was kind of a militant
atheist
and atheism at that point like new
atheism online kind of
started to get a bit social justice-y i
don't know if anyone remembers atheism
plus
and things like that so i kind of was
like oh this is interesting and that was
kind of when i when i was in in college
as well so i was like oh okay this is
this is an
up-and-coming field they were selling it
to me hard it sounded like it's going to
be an easy exam
i was mistaken so you know a confluence
of factors led me to let me to have that
as my as my undergraduate degree
also a lot of confusion in college i had
no idea what i was doing
i got into like economics uni and i was
like okay cool now i'm in the west i'm
learning western
science stuff this is good this is
status enhancing
and it's going to be great for me if i
just if i finish this uni
uh but yeah i was completely rudderless
so
you know feminism came to to embrace me
and in its warm
comforting embrace and you say you talk
about you're a militant atheist
where are you now on that because to me
a lot of
what we have now in the west with our
crisis is with our refusal to settle
down
is tied to a lack of religion do you
still are you still a militant atheist
or
have you gone somewhere different with
your thinking yeah i'm a lapsed militant
atheist
i definitely not militant um definitely
not an atheist
i i wouldn't say i'm extremely religious
but
i i am kind of returned to the
catholicism that i i
rejected um it's it's a it's it's a
journey i mean after you've been
marinating and
and you know the four horsemen for 10
years it's you know you kind of have to
you have to kind of make yourself
available to to the metaphysical in a
in a very forceful way because you know
it's you know i've seen i've kind of
marinated in these arguments for a long
time um
but i i am much more connected
to to the world of the spiritual and i
think it's
it's less so that i'm you know i've i've
read you know a book on catholicism and
i was like well i'm struck by it by the
truth of
the word of god um it was more that
i've started to doubt rationality
um i kind of started to that because
essentially
what new atheism is is there is it kind
of has a religious component it's
essentially the cult of
the homunculus you know the the the
rational individual behind the eyes
making all the decisions
you know going ahead doing didn't you
know kicking ass taking names all that
stuff
um and i started to doubt that figure or
that entity
as being you know as good as i thought
it was or at least being
being the measure of all things and
enough to
to to rule the world through um and then
you know i've kind of become a bit more
interested in
tradition you know i've tried on to see
what it feels like to
to not have to i don't know reinvent the
wheel every time you know
got married and now and i'm going to
have a baby all sorts of you know weird
old-school stuff
that people used to do back in the day
and it feels really nice i have to say
so in a way kind of i'm just i'm just
you know
riding blind through this whole you know
kind of almost traditional lifestyle
you know pickling and making bread and
doing all sorts of old school stuff and
it's
it's pretty nice i don't know i'm
probably not doing it correctly or i'm
larping or whatever
but the closer i got to to the lifestyle
of my i don't know my ancestors in a way
like my grandma used to live the
calmer and better i feel so i don't know
i'm just empirically testing this day by
day
well that's one of the things i find
quite interesting about your personal
story because
i think i i would include myself on this
a lot of people
go through the sort of 20s early 30s
period of their life
and they're doing things that aren't
making them happy but they don't
necessarily know
what they're supposed to be doing and in
the modern society they're being sold a
whole bunch of narratives about what
they should be doing and what should
make them happy
uh and quite a lot of those things they
then find out don't make them happy
aren't contributing to to a better life
or a better future
but you had whether i don't know is it
the presence of mind or whatever it
might be to go
actually i'm not this is not good
this isn't working for me and maybe i
should try my grandma's lifestyle
like how did you how did you know that
you actually need to change up
yeah i think of it was you know
empirical experiment i realized at one
point that i was completely incapable of
making good decisions about what would
make me happy
it was just like almost completely the
opposite of what i thought was gonna was
gonna do it um
you know it was good to to to go the
other way
um in in my case i
i just i don't know i was a bit
disillusioned by by what i was seeing
around me
um and yeah i i said okay you know there
there is a reason for
tradition and you know i put it putting
on my economist hat
um i just realized that you know
tradition is a heuristic it's you know
it's what people do
because it works um because it's been
robust throughout time
um and you know things like i don't know
just
working with your hands or having a
garden or things like that that are just
sound yeah sound like what old people do
to to my generation
um they really they
it's very hard to describe but it's you
know they fulfill
fulfill a need in me that is it's hard
to
you know if i had to put all my needs in
a spreadsheet i would not necessarily
know how to describe it in words or you
know to assign weights or values to it
uh but it does something you know and um
you know also pregnancy like when i was
younger i
couldn't even conceive of the idea of
having children it seemed
absolutely clear to me that i would
never have children it's absurd
i don't like babies whatever but now you
know
being going through this process it's
one of those things where you don't know
what you don't have
until it's there and yeah i think that's
probably the issue with people being
able to
predict what's going to make them happy
you really don't know until
until it happens and then you know until
until you make a commitment to something
as well i think that that's also an
important dimension because
like i said a lot of modern living is
about optionality it's about
increasing how many options you have
okay what what can i consume today
what's going to be status enhancing for
me
what's what what am i getting out of
this um
but a lot of the interesting things in
life a lot of the things that are hard
to put into words happen
when you give up on options when you
commit to something you know when you
commit
you know to doing this show to having a
family to
to building something more long-term
with someone to a friendship or
or something like that so um i feel like
we tend to optimize for the things that
we feel you know
at an expedient level are gonna make us
happy which
anything from from sweets to i don't
know
impulsive sexual encounters are gonna
fit the bill
but it's very hard to predict the the
longer term stuff
and alex do you think a large part of
this was brought on
by covid because i'll tell you from my
experience so
when i was doing comedy i was gigging
six nights a week
i was gigging in you know the best clubs
and you know it took me a long time to
get to that point
i thought i was happy i thought this is
what i wanted to do
then overnight life literally stopped
like that
and then you're left with me exactly
and what you actually realize is that
you've been dedicating your life
to a career but the reality is that
isn't fulfilling
it's nebulous it's something it doesn't
anchor you like
a family you know a relationship etc etc
was that part of the process for you
um i think i was definitely on the path
before covet but it
it has cemented it much much more
because um for example i mean i i was
i was engaged before covid and we we got
married during covet and one of these
ridiculous ceremonies but
uh um and we wanted to have a child
before that and
i was kind of you know i was pickling
before covid i have to say
but uh it did really um it strengthened
my relationship a lot you know to be in
a bunker with someone for
what is it now 14 months and to to to
feel like you know you still kind of
like them
it's quite cool um so there's a
reassuring point of confidence for your
husband that you still kind of like him
yeah yeah he's he's okay he's still
he still kind of likes me it seems so
yeah we're tolerating each other well
um and you know i've moved back to
to romania where we live in kind of a
duplex thing with
my mom's my neighbor and you know i see
her every day and we've had quite a
rocky relationship but it's it's
really improved things and i don't know
it's it's kind of
refocused me a little bit on on the as i
said the longer term stuff
the stuff that i have more skin in the
game in um you know like family and
um yeah and in a way it's also given me
a
a
lot of freedom like you know the the
podcast and you know coming on to shows
like this
is quite cool i never thought i'd i'd be
in the situation where you know people
would
ask me to respond to questions it's fun
um so yeah it's it's been it's been a
transformative time obviously it's
it's been it's not been great in many
other respects you know it's
been rocky but i think for me and a lot
of people i know so many people who are
pregnant now who
just you know decided to have coveted
babies and uh
um you know the media says oh no it's
it's a it's a sink but i don't know i've
i don't know i'm gonna believe my lying
eyes to think that you know there's
quite a
few a few covered babies popping up so
um yeah i think
you know it's been it's been a mixed
blessing for sure
do you want to promote your business to
an intelligent audience who don't need
to know your pronouns to buy your
product
here at trigonometry we have over 250
000 subscribers across the different
platforms and we frequently get
over 3 million views a month that's a
lot of new customers
for your business we speak with some of
the biggest guests from the world of
politics
economics journalism arts and
entertainment
all of them have spent at least one
month in the gulag
so you don't have to and we'll match
your product to the perfect guest for
you
american sponsors will be matched with
american guests and so on
that way you know your advert has the
best possible chance
of getting to the right people or as we
call them the wrong people
advertise with us and we'll get your
business cancelled or your money back
contact us by email at marketing
trigger pod dot co dot uk and we'll make
your nightmares come true
do you think as well that and i don't
know
that because you saw you grew up in a
catholic country romania's catholic
i my mother's orthodox or sorry orthodox
my apologies but
but my family is catholic just yeah yeah
family is catholic
do you think part of the problem with we
see in the west
is we don't talk about death death is a
taboo subject we don't mention it we
don't talk about it
and therefore we live these lives as if
we believe that it's gonna go on forever
yeah yeah the the denial of death is
really strong
in the west um i think it's it's it's
mostly because you just you don't get
confronted by death so much you know
modern medicine
you know really did a pretty good job
with the you know
averting of uh you know childhood
mortality and things like that which
were rampant or
deaths from you know infection and
things like that so you really don't get
to see
people dying as much uh you don't have
as many
family members as you used to so just
like statistical chance of people dying
around you is lower because there's just
fewer people um and i think it's it's
also
the way we you know because we've gotten
rid of rituals
you don't really make a big fuss when
people die as much as well you know you
put them in the box
you have a day and that's it you know
cremation also
you know it's just kind of like the the
self-cleaning oven of
of getting rid of people it's uh you
know
it's not we don't really integrate this
into our rituals i mean
what rituals you know if you're not
extremely religious you're not probably
don't even have a ritual related to
death and
the stories around death or just you
know typically
you see them on tv and they're just
statistics or you hear that someone died
oh my god that's
incredible like it's some some cosmic
occurrence while you know
the truth is that people people die
every day and you know you're gonna die
and
um it's you know this this memento mori
aspect of
of life is not uh is not highlighted at
all
and i mean i can understand why
it's unpleasant and we want a pleasant
life with the
pleasant you know things to watch and uh
have a comfortable everything um but i
think it's it's really valuable for
people to be confronted with death and
to be honest you see this with covet
like the how how fast
the narrative flipped from i don't know
we need to protect the nhs to
we need to conquer death which is just
absurd
and i think maybe 100 years ago people
would have known it's absurd they'd be
like
yeah you know this is this is not the
way you you mitigate this type of event
because
you know people will die the idea that
you know even if you
save someone who's you know what's
what's the main cohort for covid
you know 80 years old you you saved
their last two years
that's i don't know i don't know exactly
what type of economy that is but it's
not
it doesn't work like that and what's
interesting there as well is we're
really trying to save
so we were trying to prevent deaths
happening on television
that's what's really happened right
because we've gone after protecting that
cohort which is very reported
and completely ignored and there's quite
a lot of evidence that our government
hasn't even looked at the negative
impact ahead of time
of you know cancer heart disease all of
that stuff
because they're not happening on
television and it's it's that sort of
showy aspect of it as well isn't that
yeah it's it's a showy aspect and it's
also
what you know if you're a state you're
going to optimize stuff that's visible
to you as a state you know things that
are
legible and things that people care
about in the moment that will lead to
political pressure so what people care
about in the moment is
case rates which is a random number very
much dependent on how many
you know yeah tests are made death rates
that's interesting and also what's very
important
is anecdotal evidence in video form
that's what leads politics at the moment
if you see someone you know
a crying nurse or a desperate italian
physician or
someone a corpse being swept up by
strange you know apparatchiks and wuhan
then
yeah that's going to be very important
in terms of of how how much heft it has
and you know the direction of politics
um
so yeah in a way all the negative space
behind this like you said cancer deaths
are people who don't even get
treated or even diagnosed um doesn't
even exist
because it's hard to to to narrativize
there are no
videos of cancer deaths it's going to be
very hard to get empathy out of out of
that
let me ask you something just changing
subject a little bit uh we've got about
15 minutes left
we're talking a lot of the things that
have come as a result of what you might
describe as liberalism where has
have the forces of conservatism been
because you would think you know the
the dissolution of rituals the the the
endless freedom to do whatever you want
all of those things historically have
been held in check
by people who are a little bit more
socially conservative who say well maybe
you should you know
have a relationship before you have sex
or maybe you know
there's some things that you just do
like if a grandma dies you go to the
funeral and you're supposed to have a
funeral
with the whole family there like all of
these things that are gradually
evaporating
like what have conservatives been doing
how you know
what have they conserved um
not much not much i mean the
conservatives are
what was it like liberals you know
progressives driving the speed limit
that's essentially been the the uh the
truth about
most conservative movements in the press
i mean obviously there are some
conservative intellectuals like like
roger scrutin
or people like that who represent a
different tradition but the mainstream
of conservatism
has just you know tracked the liberals
or labor
uh by maybe five or ten years in terms
of social values
uh they're always on the back foot um
the thing is in in the
in the kind of the secular liberal
consensus you know this the the
egalitarian assumption it's not really
that much of an argument to be made
that you know you shouldn't live and let
live you shouldn't
expand freedoms you shouldn't expand uh
you know welfare and things like that
because you need a safety net
what they've been really good at is uh
is making space for the market
um to you know to create uh you know to
try to you know reduce taxes i'm all for
it you know create
more more freedom in the market reduce
regulation all this type of stuff
which has been kind of the main kind of
libertarian wing of especially u.s
conservatism
um the uk has a different flavor but
that's kind of the
the the main idea is that you know you
need to liberalize the markets and
that's you know prove some magic through
libertarian economics uh things will
will fall into place and people will
just
i don't know be socially conservative
for for one reason or another
um but the problem with that is that
for example if you have completely
globally liberalized markets
that's a bit of a solvent to social
socially conservative
ideas as well like for example if you
know
if you for example you can't get a job
in your hometown because
you know most of the jobs have been
exported to china because it's a cheaper
market to produce in
or um you know the the liberal market of
labor demands that you leave the place
where you are
to find the perfect job for you
somewhere else um
or did you go to college to get the
skills that you need to climb up in
in the in the in the hierarchy um all
this stuff
is you know is is a solvent it's as you
know if you can't be socially
conservative
if you if you don't respect the fact
that people may want to live in a
certain locality
may want to i don't know have a have a
more
legacy style job or be be home to take
care of their children
you know because the liberal market
wants people to uh to produce
so women being in the marketplace
working full-time
is a big aspect of libertarian economics
as well and you know people want to
increase their labor force participation
so there's all of these things that are
geared towards the market
and if something's geared specifically
towards
increasing productivity gdp whatever
type of
measure you want to bring in it's
obviously not geared towards protecting
the things that are not the market
which many times consist of these more
traditional institutions which you know
kind of are left by the wayside so
i think in a way conservatives have you
know
with all good intentions they've shot
themselves in the foot on social issues
with with this strategy because you need
to have a priority
if social conservatism is your priority
well then that
that is a value that's higher than the
market and it has never been
higher than the market in the last
whatever 50 years
and isn't it the problem as well that
you know all these values that you talk
about which you associate with social
conservatism you can't monetize them
and in a consumerist society they
therefore get ranked down in the pecking
order
yeah absolutely i mean what's what's the
value of
taking care of a sick relative you know
what's you know who's gonna pay you for
that
uh if if you can't if you can't get jeff
bezos to pay you to
to do that on on you know uh from
as a nine to five then is it even
happened you know
did it even make a sound uh so yeah like
you said if it's not reflected in
in the in the main uh ladder of value
that we have then
you know it's it's it doesn't exist it's
valueless therefore it will disappear
eventually
so what science alex what what's what's
a political position that you think is a
is healthy as a response to all of the
things we've been talking about for the
last 50 minutes
yeah this this is uh this is a tricky
one you know a lot of people have a lot
of ideas of of how to do this
it's it's it's a hard one because you
know what we're living it on
in the west is kind of the the
scaffolding of kind of this
judeo-christian value system
um and you know it still works it's got
some holes but you know there is there
are some core values that
exist there even though we pretend that
they don't exist and we're eroding them
with with every step
um i don't think you can have a
political system that doesn't have
a value system behind it um how
where that value system needs to grow
out of you know there's there's schools
like you know catholic integralism where
you kind of have you know
catholicism as that value system which
you know we used to have in
europe you know in this heyday you know
there are good things about it bad
things about it
um but at the same time the idea that
okay we're just going to have a value of
society
and see how that goes the problem with
that is that
it gets taken over by people who have
values and woke
is is a very strong moral system and
it's essentially
come into a space that said oh you know
our value is that we have no values
well these guys have values and they
will they will come and trample yours to
the ground because
you know don't tread on me cool but how
about this you know this millenarian
cult that wants to
to to you know show you that you know
you're you're fallen
and you know it has all the all the
trappings of an old school hardcore cult
um and it's it's it's offers a really
powerful vision and
offers very powerful morality uh and it
will take your system over so
you know i i don't exactly know what
type of morality we need to
you know instantiate in our political
system but i really don't think
it you can go without any so
i don't know pure libertarianism i think
just collapses because the the game
theory of it doesn't work
something will come in to fill the void
and you know
now we know in a way we're all talking
here because something has come in to
fill the void and it's absolutely
bonkers
so yeah i i don't know it's um
but but also on a personal level because
i think you know politics is one level
but
i think you know people can live good
lives in the current regime
um if they if they just kind of try to
look at reality
a little bit closer you know like we
were talking about how do you want your
life to be
you know maybe look a bit back at
tradition
it can be helpful um there are certain
things that you don't know
maybe defer to other other people or
maybe to faith traditions or
traditions in general in some directions
so
yeah i don't know a bit more humility at
the the personal level can can be quite
helpful
let me just ask one follow-up see the
thing with that thinking and i i i am
increasingly convinced as well that the
answer to this
needs to start with the individual where
you live a life
that actually works for you as you seem
to be doing and and
uh you know pursuing a purpose and
family
and community and contributing and you
know challenging yourself and you know
cleaning your room and all that great
stuff right
but at the same time you know you you've
got a baby on the way and
congratulations by the way
that baby's going to be born seven years
from now that baby's going to go to
school
where they're going to be taught that
they don't have a gender and
and all of that i don't think that's
going to be taught in romania man let me
be honest with you maybe it's catching
up i'd be surprised
yeah it's right right it's all it's all
downstream
yeah so but that's that's why i've
always thought about it that's why i've
always
made a stand against it because it's
going to spread right so
you know you've lived your perfect life
you've taught your your child up until
the age of seven you know this is right
this is wrong this is how you do this is
how you do that this is how you think
about this don't have sex before then
whatever all of that great stuff
and then they go to school and they
clash with a completely different
institutionalized culture which is as
you said yourself bonkers
now what do you do then because it's no
longer about you it's about your family
yeah yeah believe me i've you know i've
thought about this from
from every angle um so i don't want to
put you off having the baby by the way
it's a bit like it's a bit similar
exactly
you've made your bed you know what i
mean
yeah it's um yeah i've definitely
thought about this and
i've written about it as well i'm you
know it's it's a it's it's a hard
it's a hard time especially because my
my baby is going to be male
and he's going to be white are you going
to bring a straight white male
into the oh how dare you let's cancel
actually we don't know if it's going to
be straight yet yeah exactly we don't
even know if it's going to be male we
need to wait until it's 18th birthday
that's when you do the gender reveal
party
[Music]
exactly um yeah it's you know it's it's
it's a hard thing
the the issue is you know no parent ever
could
you know completely control the world
view of their child
um you know my my plan my tactical
toolkit is to provide a stable
calm you know good-natured home
hopefully if i'm if i don't you know
change personalities overnight if i have
a baby
but um and and also kind of just just
model
a good life to the child i feel like a
lot of people especially in my
generation have had
um parents that you know came from quite
disorganized environments you know
everyone talks about boomer parents and
things like that where you know
children of divorce you know people who
are really enthralled
with the um with this idea of the
individual
you know of you know constantly choosing
choosing maybe to divorce your spouse or
you know having
affairs and then being you know quite a
quite a
i don't know you know trying to optimize
yourself quite a bit too much if you
have if you try to build a stable family
so
that's something i will try very hard
not to do and to
you know to provide um yeah a good
background for
for the child and yeah he he will have
to deal with reality at one point
and um in a way i feel you can't do
much better by your child than to you
know just set set
the um put the seeds right
and set the background for him to to to
grow and
and yeah exist in a in a stable way
um and also i'm gonna let my husband
teach him about you know
being being a man and all the manly
things and not gonna try to
interfere with this skateboarding or
whatever whatever
one should not do with boys so
yeah i think you know i just i
i'm kind of a pro-natalist i think you
know it's um
it's good to have children you know the
world's i didn't expect the world to be
the way it is now and i
probably can't make any predictions
about how it's going to be in five years
i think technology really is a bit of a
kerosene
that exists in these cultural spaces and
i feel like you know you can have
things cascading one way or the other
quite suddenly so i'm i'm just going to
try to prepare him
as much as i can um you know without
trying to you know
fill his head with dogma or whatever but
but also now trying to trying to
strengthen him for
yeah whatever might come alex well those
are very very
powerful words to end the interview on
we always end our interviews with
one final question which is uh what is
the one thing we're not talking about as
a society but we really should be
i think um one thing that people aren't
talking about
is um migration
and kind of in migration of intelligence
and kind of strip mining the world for
uh very intelligent people
moving them to cities uh and also kind
of
putting them in in this issue that i
just laid out at the beginning of the
show the idea that you know it's it's
it's a it's not a good place to have
children so essentially
you know it's it's uh you're you're
creating these fertility sinks in cities
um cities have always been fertility
sinks but now they've you know they've
really made a machine out of it um and
you're taking
some of the most brilliant people from
around the world and putting them there
and
yeah kind of not not creating the
conditions for
this intelligence to perpetuate and i
think you know intelligence is quite
terrible and it would be nice to have
some left in a few generations and
i think this might be a bigger problem
than people think
so i mean i haven't heard many people
talk about this i think it's
it's a tough one and i think you know
it's like kind of like antibiotic
resistance
it's like ah you don't deal with it
until you have to so i think we'll see a
little
bit of of this on the horizon maybe in
50 years
great a generation of stupid people
something that we can all look forward
to yeah
idiocracy is proving to be quite
prophetic
it is uh alex great chatting to you uh
thank you for coming on the show
uh people can follow you on twitter they
can read your is it stop
sub stack your minds mostly putting
stuff out
yeah that's that's where my writing is
um yeah and also my podcasts and
yeah some of the subversive podcasts
yeah but make sure you check it out and
thank you for watching at home we will
see you very soon
with another brilliant interview like
this one and they always go out
as well as our raw shows
shows at 7pm uk time well done mate
thank you
i nailed it take care and see you soon
guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe
and hit the bell button so that you
never miss another fantastic episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using
the link below